these are times of tumultuous change the
20th century order is history and the
forces of globalization are pushing all
of the economies of the world more
closely together and all of the citizens
of the world more closely together with
their great diversity of religious
faiths global interdependence therefore
is a reality and faith is inextricably
linked to that interdependence as we've
seen faith can be a source of division
and destruction but faith can also be a
source of reconciliation and creativity
not complete the Tony Blair Faith
Foundation aims to promote the positive
role of the world's faiths in the global
realities of the 21st century and to
demonstrate the beneficial results the
people of diverse faiths working
together can accomplish together one key
way in which the foundation hopes to
accomplish these aims is through
education so I'm delighted to be
partnering with Yale University and
specifically with its divinity school
and school of management to create the
faith and globalization course which I
will coat each with members of the Yale
faculty the course itself is just one
aspect of our cooperative efforts in
addition to becoming an ongoing course
at Yale we expect that the curricula and
the ideas originated at Yale will serve
as the foundation for other courses and
other universities around the world we
also intend the course to stimulate
influential academic research in this
critically important area and i hope the
related materials to be found on this
website will serve as a global resource
for scholars and citizens alike indeed
for anyone who's interested in learning
about the world's diverse religions
their potential roles for the greater
public good in the global economy and
the interactions between the great face
and the dynamics of globalization I hope
that the work will be of interest and
value to everyone who believes as I do
that values must unify
I and not divide us and also that faith
can serve as a means for peace progress
and prosperity for all the peoples of
the world thank you